Hi dent you et pour h&m detox opera
[Music]
Closed Like cold coffee, I made a deal Is mom and dad the Holy Spirit gave
me j In other words, it's day Cleansing Art Gum goes a little further Follow the result.
woo woo
Oh my gosh 10 things 9
we see my own a choi
toie
[Music] I
did 5 From now on
write Effort r2
equipped shot window one to one clap clap clap clap clap
odor in the car setting Odor tails trying to catch
a thread a Beat till the end of the sunset Clap
calmly  4th 5 clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap clap
[Music]
Weather
Ouch 7 Loosen the rice in the wiring and pierce it
5 Write another pendulum Advance after voting Sam gets tangled Defeated
Ah number squad I don’t know 4w Can’t dry 5 Teeth alternate Came Write
tail  Even if I calm down, it's right,
I'm going to go Bara, brica, I'm going to go to the fairway, Cho-Eel Cho-Am Mono Give me an atmosphere
Throw top down or I'll go
Second y Raja a very very low the we are made
to her own beer
Rather than a mat announcement I'm going to buy a fire wall Am Sure Narae
3 c
only  we also were
we uh group 3
euk siwoo ger
love c living is a lack of
words no matter what you say, you leave me who cherished only one thing wow why did you go so close to
me ah got it secretly
[Music]
Who
's
that?
4 september back underground
[Music]
where
where ah uh
why ah tel uh uh
to we we we we we we
[Music] uh uh
[Music]